Greta gerwig's Bobby is dominating at
the box office but it's not just kids
queuing up to see the doll come to life
the fantasy comedy thinks outside the
box with plenty of clever moments only
adults will likely notice
okay so let's do this that's the voice
over in Barbie points out the Barbies
don't always behave like humans do
because they're dolls being played with
by humans for example kids rarely use
the staircases that come with Barbie
Dreamhouses which is why Margot Robbie's
stereotypical Bobby simply floats three
stories to the ground below when she
needs to get to the first floor suddenly
the water at the beach are stuck in a
permanent plastic cresting wave so when
Ryan Gosling's Ken tries to dive in and
impress Bobby he Rico Shades off the
solid water and ends up in the hospital
those details are pretty obvious as is
the fact that when Barbies take showers
or poor drinks no liquid actually comes
out of the faucet or the milk carton but
look a little closer at the Barbie land
that director Greta Gerwig and the
production designers have created and
even more accurate and hilarious study
details will reveal themselves like the
stickers that make up the contents of
Barbie's refrigerator or the water in
Barbie's pool plus when Barbie is
driving a pink convertible he doesn't
always have a Hands on the Wheel these
creative decisions not only make Barbie
land feel more authentic that assortment
material they're great visual jokes and
part of why Barbie is one of the
funniest movies of the year
the teaser trailer for Barbie that hit
YouTube in December 2022 generated Buzz
for being a parody of Stanley Cube
breaks 2001 A Space Odyssey fans may
have assumed the clip was just clever
advertising and that only the final
frames of the teaser contained footage
from the movie itself but the 2001 riff
actually appears in Barbie as a prologue
of sorts from there Gerber's film
contains Myriad references to famous
films that came before it and many of
them are from before gen Z's time when
Ken crosses into the real world he
discovers Rocky in a dub Sylvester
Stallone's personal style as his own
later when the Barbies conspire to
overthrow the Kens one pretends to have
never seen The Godfather triggering a
mansplaining watch session the most
overt night is to another Warner Bros
film when Alexander's ship's writer
Barbie is the programmed she can't
believe she was so invested in the
Steiner cut while under the Ken's
influence Barbie's disco party resembles
the dancing and set from Saturday Night
Fever the choice of shoes is a spoof of
the red and blue pills and the Matrix
the Ken's travel on hobby horseback like
the knights in Monty Python and the
Grail and the Musical Battle of the
Ken's features iconography and
choreography that's similar to West Side
Story and degrees
Bobby has a stellar cast led by Margot
Robbie and Ryan Gosling we were getting
Oscar bows for their performances it's
rounded out by a mix of comic Legends
like Rhea Pullman and Kate McKinnon and
the merging Stars such as Emma Maki simu
Liu and Kinsey benedir in particular
including Will Ferrell as Mattel CEO was
a stroke of Brilliance Barbie closely
parallels 2003's elf and 2014's a Lego
Movie both of which feature Farrell
doing some of his best work like buddy
Barbies are two innocent fish out of
water when she reaches a real world and
like Emmett she learns that she doesn't
have to be an astronaut or the president
to be special feral is a goofy
protagonist and elf and the evil Lord
Business in The Lego Movie here he's
another corporate villain and one who
makes the inverse of Buddy's Journey
kids May recognize him from his earlier
appearances but only perceptive teens
and adults will understand what gerwig's
doing with this stunt casting wrestling
fans probably caught John Cena's Cameo
as a mermaid but other cameos would be
lost on younger viewers Annie momolo who
example shows up as anxiety mom momolo
is a co-writer and co-star of 2021's Bob
and star go to Vista Del Mar another
comedy that shares an aesthetic and tone
with Bobby
to the surprise of parents everywhere
Bobby was released with the PG-13 rating
It's Not Unusual for family films to
earn that designation every entry in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and most Star
Wars films carry the same rating and so
do Blockbusters that a lot of the Rings
and Jurassic Park most of those contain
significantly more cursing and violence
and Barbie dust so why wasn't the movie
about a children's toy able to earn a PG
one reason could be the number of double
entenderers in the script in other words
Barbie is full of jokes that are
specifically designed to go over kids
heads the first one audience's encounter
is a gag that was featured in the
trailer but Ken's trying to outken each
other repeatedly threatened to beat each
other off as Beach is Ken's career later
goslings can suggest he wants to stay
over though he doesn't fully understand
the idiom to do what
I'm actually not sure anyone who's ever
seen a Greta garbage movie should have
expected there to be feminist themes but
as it turns out the whole premise of
Barbie is a feminist exercise that
examines patriarchal society by
comparing it to the girl-powered fantasy
of Barbie land the Barbies mistakenly
believe that because they've achieved
something Beyond parity real women in
the real world face their obstacles in
attaining their dreams months in Los
Angeles Barbie is shocked and Ken is
thrilled at how wrong they were Bobby
feels a constant looming threat of
physical and sexual violence or
Canfield's only affirmation she's
flabbergasted at the all-male board of
directors at Mattel while Ken asks for a
high-powered high-paying job at a
different company and an executive tells
them they still do patriarchy they're
just better at hiding him when the
Barbies re-ratify their constitution
it's telling that they only let Ken
serve on Lower circuit courts of course
this isn't fair but the dog joke is that
it took women centuries of small steps
like these to get where they are today
which is still nowhere near Fuller
quality based on paying representation
in the end Barbie chooses neither love
nor career but the chance to find out
who she he is during the course of a
finite and imperfect life which is its
own kind of feminist statement but
gerberg really drives home a point with
Gloria's rousing monologue during which
she laments how impossible it is to live
right as a female yeah I cried too it's
actually kind of amazing
Gloria's Epiphany inspires her to pitch
the idea of an ordinary Barbie Will
Ferrell's CEO character assumes it would
never sell but when an underling does
some quick calculations and informs him
that ordinary Barbie would be a hit to
make money the boss changes his opinion
on a dime the underlying message
throughout anything having to do with
the Mattel plot is that no matter how
much the company claims it exists
altruistically show girls women that
they can be anything they want to be
that bug serpent put a price tag on any
hunk of plastic that would sell that
becomes apparent when Bobby lands turned
Kingdom's effect on the real world
transforms Barbie Dreamhouses into Ken
Mojo Dojo cutter houses and they start
flying off of store shelves granted the
CEO wants to revert that change but
they're still making money in the
meantime although Barbie is unavoidably
a corporate tie-in and a product in and
of itself the script takes pains to
interrogate the many ways in which
capitalism and Barbie are inextricably
linked at one point Margot Robbie's
stereotypical Bobby even describes her
self-worth by proudly claiming that
she's accumulated a lot of great stuff
ironically the movie that pokes fun at
his own capitalist benefactor is also
making a ton of dough not only if I'm
better than expected ticket sales but
from corporate collaborations this irony
as well as Barbie's meta commentary on
Commerce are beyond the interests of
grade school age moviegoers one of the
biggest clues of Barbie is not so
secretly for 30 somethings and up is the
fact that so much of the world Greta
Gerwig recreates us from the 80s and 90s
but some other reference points go back
even further into Barbie history which
shows itself a subplot thread in the
movie The prologue tells the tale of
Barbie's arrival on the scene as girls
stare at the original 1959 Barbie in a
black and white chevron bathing suit
from there the story pauses to make note
of either iconic or ill-advised products
from Barbie's past that's Barbie's
purple and silver ice capades outfit
from 1990 plus vintage disco and paisy
numbers Gloria gets giddy when she
notices the 1985 Treehouse said she had
as a child upon driving through Barbie
land and weird Barbies pooping dog has
been released by Mattel multiple times
oh my
well kids might think some of the bad
idea Barbies and Kenza funny only mature
Bobby viewers will feel Nostalgia for
discontinued dolls like Michael Sarris
Allen or Emerald fennel's Midge
Barbie is possibly the most fun movie
about anxiety and depression ever made
kids may have heard of those sums before
and some may have even experienced them
after all the film's inciting incident
has to do with stereotypical Barbies
fear of death which leads her to seek
out the girl who owns her so that she
can figure out why she's sad but Bobby
isn't about to generalize anxiety it's
about female anxiety the kind that grips
girls as they go through puberty and
become women and the kind that hinders
adult women just trying to get through
the day Bobby's own anxiety begins when
she realizes she has bad breath the
first sign of her previously Unthinkable
imperfection from there she begins to
fret about cellulite and not being
beautiful anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
Sasha and Gloria are clearly struggling
too it strongly implied their societal
expectations play a role in these
deep-seated worries Barbie puts forth at
cultural norms mean women have little
choice but to stress about their looks
their demeanor their intelligence their
professionalism and their parenting in a
way that men perhaps are not but that
doesn't mean men don't have their own
anxieties or that people don't
regardless of gender Harbor similar
fears it's just that Barbie is relating
specifically to an audience of women who
have tried to have it all and found it
mentally and physically exhausting
in addition to its weighty thoughts on
the role of gender in society gervix
Barbie is really interested in death and
deities yes Bobby's existential dread
stems from Sasha and Gloria's issues but
stereotypical Barbie goes on to have an
emotional and spiritual crisis all her
own while she's trying to escape from
Mattel headquarters Barbie opens an
unmarked door and wanders into a kitchen
where mysterious Whitehead woman begins
to give her some advice the most art and
Bobby fans may have guessed it ahead of
time but eventually we learned that this
is Ruth Handler inventor of Barbie
Barbie concludes with a moving scene in
which the senshin doll literally meets
her Creator Ruth tells Barbie that she
was named after her daughter Barbara
which adds even more meaning to the
film's rumination on the relationships
between mothers and daughters and facing
her God Bobby must also face a difficult
Choice she can live forever in her dream
world or she can live once in the real
world another interpretation of a
journey mirrors a story of Adam and Eve
but in Reverse as far as Ken is
concerned in which humans are expelled
from the Garden of Eden ultimately
Barbie decides that being a person is
better than being an idea and accepts
the imperfection of Life ideas live
forever these religious themes are no
accident Gerwig told the Associated
Press that the biblical story to my
Catholic upbringing but foundational to
Bobby
we're living through a cultural pendulum
swinging which identity politics have
become increasingly hot button
especially in the Spheres of the
entertainment industry and advertising
Disney remakes replacing white actors
generate anger online and Brands like
Bud Light Target and even Chick-fil-A
have come under Fire by organized
opposition for supporting the lgbtq
community and diversity initiatives
there's been a backlash to Bobby at
least on social media if not at the box
office but is primarily centered on the
perception that the film is anti-man the
fact that a trans actress Harry Neff
plays Dr Bobby has gone relatively
unchallenged in the mainstream as has
the fact that the film showcases
multiple Barbies and cans of color
that's probably because despite the fact
that the doll the movie is based on is
blonde Buxom and often sexualized
there's no real sexuality in Barbie at
all not to mention the film is having
fun with gender Norms or both embracing
and rejecting them Barbie reminds people
that she and Ken don't have genitals and
they don't so much as kiss most kids
likely left the theater never having
realized never transactress similarly
most likely never gave a second thought
to the diverse Barbies in Ken's because
the toy line itself has been multiracial
since 1968 plus Barbie also features a
Barbie who uses a wheelchair in the
disco party scene like the one that hit
store shelves in 1997.
foreign